what are you trying to what are you
trying to get at what language did Jesus
speak I understand where you about to
try to lead that to that's not relevant
one second I'll be right back I'll be
right back sorry I had to get my
utensils you just said that everything
you know about Jesus comes from the
Quran okay what language did Jesus speak
le you claim that he spoke Greek you
claim that he spoke Hebrew I mean I
didn't CLA anything I've heard you I've
heard you make that stop trying to drop
out the pot stay in there stop trying to
drop out the pot what language did Jesus
speak what's the argument for today why
do Muslims dislike Paul why do Muslims
dislike Paul oh you finally switch it up
man that's what's up I try to be
versatile man you know try to throw in a
little little new ones I'm proud of you
man you trying to come with more
arguments but
uh I'll be even more proud
say your shahada but uh yeah why do we
dislike Paul you know what I I'll say
I'll say my shahada if you can give good
and consistent reasons why you dislike
Paul as long as they don't backfire oh
yeah well number one or kind of like the
last guy was saying who is Paul like how
do we even know we don't really know
much about Paul we we actually don't
know nothing about Paul outside of the
Bible not at all like no sort like who's
his parents what does that matter tell
me his mother or his father's name no
why does that matter cuz I mean whenever
whenever somebody whenever like like for
example if I said if I said God logic
said this and it's just a claim it'll be
like how you know how you know God logic
said that how does knowing my mom and
dad's name verify what I said or didn't
say so it's to verify that that person
that's taking this
information actually knows this person
and is a firsthand witness account what
does that that still is not telling me
anything knowing the name of my mother
and father does not validate or
invalidate what I say today like if you
ask somebody if they said oh yeah Avery
said this and you say oh okay well who
who is Avery actually like do you what's
his mom and dad's name and they don't
know does that invalidate that I said
what they said I said no no no no no but
no but the real no but realistically it
would be it would be more so so and so
said this about so and so was witness
God saying this then it would be like
okay how do you know God logic yeah did
you watch him on Tik Tok did you meet
him in person can somebody know me
without knowing my Mom and Dad yeah well
that was just an example I gave Mom and
Dad but but it's the first thing you
it's more than just yeah yeah no so it's
more than just that okay so so let's
throw that out then let's throw
knowledge of parents is out the window
from now on and I hope that the rest of
the Muslims hear this this is a silly
thing to bring up
when it comes to knowing if somebody
said something or not so what is the
real problem that you have with Paul
well of course one that but number two
um you said I thought we threw that out
you threw it out I still I still take
that as substantial I I feel like that's
something substantial make claims you
have to show me then you have to show me
that that's substantial show me that
I'll concede to that okay so the that
I'll come I'll come with better I'll
come with better evidence towards that
later so it's out the window for now I
can see to that for now all right so
it's out the window all right go ahead
what's so what's number one then give me
give me something yeah so number one I
don't believe Paul ever met Jesus okay
and let's go with that you gota continue
y Paul didn't meet Jesus so Paul not
meeting Jesus does that make him
unreliable it doesn't it doesn't make
him unreliable as a person but if he
speaks on Jesus MH and he never met
Jesus then that makes him unreliable got
it so
it doesn't mean that he's unreliable
personally but if he speaks on Jesus
right says that Jesus said things or
taught certain things or whatever but
never met him himself then that would
mean he's unreliable pertaining to the
to Jesus gotcha correct all right so
let's just go with that did Muhammad
meet Jesus yes Muhammad met
Jesus you want me to tell you when when
did Muhammad meet Jesus on the night
Journey you got it I didn't to tell you
I'm proud of youly Li you be doing your
studying good job good job he met all
the prophets you me give you an example
watch this no it's all it's all good
it's all good you got it he met him in
the night did Jesus did Jesus meet Moses
it's it's all good Yes actually but it's
okay thank you no but Jesus actually met
Moses while he was here on Earth but you
also claim that okay you claim that as
being believing that he's the god of the
Old Testament sure okay that's cool in
the
newest the in the New Testament Moses
and what was it Aaron appear to yeah
yeah yeah you you get it so so they so
he so he appeared
so met Jesus but yeah but but Moses was
but Moses was not alive at that time no
God is the god of the living not the
dead Abraham all of them they're Alive
With God just just like how just like
how the Quran says that the martyrs are
alive with Allah they're not dead yes
yes they're in another they're alive in
another realm but as of a Earthly realm
Jesus was on earth when he this Jesus
was on earth when he said that they
appeared so did they come down from
heaven and appear on Earth yeah so the
Angels could I mean so the prophets
could come down from heaven yeah on
Earth yeah by the power of God yeah is
wait wait time out time out time out so
so any of the prophets at any time can
appear on Earth yeah if God wants them
to yeah what what what would be the need
of that there is no need for him to do
anything he could do that if he wants
though right but why would he why would
he want his
Prophet that because they already
completed their job well I'm showing you
that you have the disciples that are
there witnessing Jesus so this is their
first time witnessing the glory of Jesus
and they're even witnessing Muhammad and
Elijah coming to him submitting to him
and then the voice from Heaven the
father who declares that that's his son
who they should listen to so all of this
is for the benefit not of Jesus or
anybody else it's for the disciples that
are there to show okay that you know
okay yeah this is the one okay got you
okay understood so wait I have a
question what's your so so wait wait so
what's your opposition to the night
Journey then if you if you accept that
what is your opposition well I don't
accept it but let's just go with it no
no I'm saying if you accept that Elijah
and uh Moses appeared if you accept that
what why do you oppose the prophet going
to heaven and talking to them but you
but you don't oppose the prophets being
on Earth you're not listening to me bro
I don't I'm not I'm not I'm not opposing
you I'm actually going with you so if
you're saying that that Muhammad met
Jesus on the night Journey which you
know as theist and spiritually you know
miraculously maybe that could happen we
should have no problem with that type of
stuff so then I would say then you
shouldn't oppose Paul meeting Jesus when
he was on his way to Damascus this is
where this is where I oppose that why
number one number one Isa Mariam I don't
know who that is but okay I don't know
who Jesus is because was because it's
because it's it's Aus in the uh 19 in
the 1611 and then Yeshua and I'm not
even gonna go through all that but
anyways I'm not about to go through all
that but anyways you get the idea but
anyways a prophet leaving this planet
God ascended him and we understand that
he's not to come back until he is needed
to come back again um we don't or until
come on he's not to come back until the
day of judgment look you you exp wait Le
please you explaining the night journey
and your interpretation of that is
irrelevant here you believe that in some
miraculous realm some spiritual thing
took place to where that allowed
Muhammad to meet the rest of the
prophets fine you don't even have to
interpret the deepness of that you can
have it okay so just deal with if you
accept that why do you oppose Paul
meeting Jesus on the on his way to
Damascus gotcha gotcha okay so we both
accept something miraculous could happen
all right so the way that you the way
the reason I oppose that is because the
way that you would understand if this
vers is being truthful or not is because
from the sustenance of what they're
speaking so Paul
oh so you don't you don't deny that Jes
that Paul could have met really met
Jesus on the road to Damascus you only
go against him meeting Jesus because you
don't believe what Paul taught well Paul
he number well according to the Bible
which of course I don't accept it as
Authority but according to the Bible it
says things that like for example Jesus
he spoken Parables Paul never mentioned
that um wait that that not that's not a
denial of Jesus speaking in Parables
come on man but but but what I'm saying
what I'm
saying wait wait wait before you
continue before you continue look so now
it sounds like so at first the issue was
Paul didn't meet Jesus and now we see
that that's not really an issue the
issue is now switching to well it's what
Paul Tau it's what Paul taught okay so
Paul says that he met Jesus right
but doesn't mention that Jesus taught in
Parables so that makes him unreliable is
that correct so you kind of
misrepresented my point I'm not saying
that I'm not I'm not granting that he
met Jesus I'm saying that what he taught
makes me believe that he never met Jesus
I know so we have this claim from both
sides Muhammad claims that he met Jesus
Paul claims that he met Jesus okay and
so you're showing me why you believe one
but not the other so we have the claim
from Paul however you don't believe Paul
actually met Jesus because boom because
he doesn't mention if he if he met Jesus
he would have mentioned that when Jesus
was here he taught in Parables but Paul
never said anything about that is that
correct yep okay Muhammad also says that
he met Jesus Jesus spoke in Parables
does Muhammad mention that Jesus spoke
in Parables Muhammad didn't he he or the
well
I'm not going to speak on everything
that he said about that because I don't
know everything surrounding that but but
what I do know is I like I don't know
about him having a full conversation
with Jesus in that night Journey but I'm
not but I'm not going to speak on that
because I don't have knowledge on that
but but what I speak on is what Allah
has taught us about Jesus or what I
believe Allah taught us about Jesus well
well I'm confused here okay I'm confused
here Paul didn't mention how Jesus
taught in Parables yet he met him
Muhammad also I guess the answer is no
right Muhammad didn't mention that Jesus
taught in Parables is that correct I
don't have knowledge on that I do not
have from what you know you don't know
of any mention of Muhammad saying that
Jesus taught in Parables right I haven't
read all the Hadith on it so I don't I
don't know I'm I'm just I'm just asking
based on what you do know based on what
you do know there is no mention of
Muhammad saying that Jesus taught in
Parables from what you know so far right
sure yeah I haven't read anything of
that yet no worries so you have Muhammad
who doesn't say that Jesus taught him
Parables yeah Paul Paul who doesn't
mention how Jesus taught in Parables you
said that this makes Paul's claim of his
experience meeting Jesus false so then
likewise it would make Muhammad's claim
of meeting Jesus false right if we're
consistent so I wouldn't say that
necessarily
necessarily because number
one like I said I do not know all the
circumstances surrounding the meeting of
Jesus I just know that he did meet Jesus
along the way I do not know everything
surrounding it but everything that I
learned from Jesus I don't get from the
prophet I get it from the Quran and what
God what I believe God is speaking
directly of him when God says that he
Muslim God knows everything so that's
what I understand I know Paul doesn't
know everything I got you I got you I
got Paul could have been hallucinating
God so and and and Muhammad could have
been a hallucinating too right no so you
and and I like the chuckle there I like
I like the chuckle because lie I think
you're smart enough to see your double
standards see all notice how Le I
haven't even like refuted anything
you've said about muhamad right I
haven't I haven't said anything I
haven't gone against it in any way all
I've done was just apply your own logic
back to Muhammad to see if you would be
consistent and every time I do you
flipflop and you show your double
standard can you at least be honest with
me and say and and and acknowledge that
you do see the double standard that
you're applying here no I do understand
where you're coming from I understand
the angle that you're coming from and
you're saying okay if you believe this
why don't you believe that I understand
the angle that you're coming from uh but
it's more to it than just those things
it's all of these things all
but we see okay good but here it is we
see all of these things combined
together these accusations and these
problems that you have with Paul all of
these things combined together can be
also applied to Muhammad but you're not
willing to apply them to Muhammad you're
only willing to apply them to Paul do
you then and that's where the
inconsistency and the double standard is
being exposed that's what I'm doing I'm
saying that if you're going to say Paul
is unreliable and false for all of these
reasons combined then you have to say
Muhammad is false for all of those same
reasons combined not necessarily and I'm
not really trying to speak on the
prophet I'm just trying to speak on what
I understand of Paul not really trying
to speak on Islam itself
but look I just I showed you my hand my
whole hand in my cards the reason for
this topic is to expose Muhammad and
expose y'all's beliefs in Muhammad I'm
showing you that your accusations
against Paul actually work against
Muhammad so if you're going to say that
Paul is a false messenger a false
prophet a false teacher unreliable for
the reasons that you give then you have
to say Muhammad is false and unreliable
for those same reasons that's my point
well it also go it's it's also is more
to that like for example Paul's
character he openly admits to being a
liar he openly admits to having a thorn
of Satan being in his flesh he openly
admits to robbing the church's blind he
openly admits being a Jew to those were
Jews for them one at a time leave one at
a time you cooking right now so now it
has switched over we see the accusation
against Paul's claim of having a
spiritual experience compared to
Muhammad's claim of having an exper a
spiritual experience and the reason
why Le here doesn't believe Paul but
believes Muhammad those same reasons are
the same reasons why he can't believe
Muhammad actually met Jesus and had a
spiritual experience but in short Le
says not trying I'm not trying to bring
theet into it no I'm not trying to bring
the prophet into haveo what I know what
I know what I know of Jesus comes from
the Quran really what language did Jesus
speak what language he speak what are
you trying to what are you trying to get
at what language did Jesus speak I
understand where you about to try to
lead that to that's not relevant that's
like me asking you time out that's like
me asking you what language did Adam
speak what language did Adam speak one
second I'll be right back I'll be right
back sorry I had to get my utensils what
language did he speak what language did
he speak bro he making all that noise
I'm just trying to because I'm stirring
I'm stirring it I'm cooking I just gotta
anyway what what language did he speak
that is not Rel it doesn't matter like
that does not matter to a person like me
can I tell you why it matters because
you just said you just said that
everything you know about Jesus and
everything you learn from Jesus comes
from the Quran okay let's see if that
actually holds what language did Jesus
speak le you claim that he spoke Greek
you claim that he spoke
Hebrew I didn't CLA anything I've heard
you I've heard you make that claim
pot stay in there what
language stop trying to drop out the pot
what language did Jesus speak I
understand where you're gonna go you're
gonna say oh the Quran doesn't tell you
that okay I didn't say that but what
language yeah did Jesus speak the
language that the Hebrews or that the
Hebrew spoke at that time arame AR the
Jews spoke at that time arame is that in
your Quran come on bro is that in your
kran I just told you your argument
before you said it very good is it in
kran no the people around him spoke that
language wow so where do you get it from
actually lean where do you get it from
that Jesus spoke Aramaic and lived with
people who spoke Hebrew and Aramaic
where' you get that from there are
sources that go that are around that
time there's many of sources don't just
say the Bible I I didn't say anything
but but so what sources tell you that
Jesus spoke Aramaic the Jews of that
time spoke
Aramaic what source do you have that
says Jesus spoke Aramaic remember the
Jews were everywhere they were all over
the place they were in Arabia they were
uh in Egypt they were all over the place
what tell you don't think I don't think
I don't think that matters though like
regardless let's say he spoke Chinese I
don't think it matters oh it does matter
I don't think it matters oh it matters
why does it matter because what matters
is is you just said that everything you
know about Jesus comes from the Quran
but yet you just gave me some
information about Jesus that doesn't
come from the Quran yet you stated it as
fact so wherever you're getting this
from you're relying on it as your
historical fact on the life of Jesus at
least in this aspect so what source is
that that tells you that Jesus spoke
arama bro you're gonna say the only two
there's only two phrases in the Bible
that he ever uses that were quotequote
Aramaic
and ABA that's the only two things that
you'll say so are you
saying I say I can say go I can say e I
can say different things but does that
mean I speak Spanish so so just here's
the question that's why I feel like it's
not it's not
relevant the matter so what what source
tells you that he spoke Aramaic you're
close you're so hot man you're you're
right there you're saying that like only
one thing says it I'm only asking you
what's the source what is it just say it
so we can move on bro I just said
there's only two phrases it doesn't say
Jesus spoke Aramaic it said he said in
this in this
language okay sure so the Bible demon I
say so is the source the Bible it it
makes a claim that he said something but
is so is the source the Bible I don't
believe that he said that I don't
believe he said my God my God wor you
forsaking me he I don't even believe he
said that so
to jump out the pot stop it he never got
crucified so I don't even accept that no
worries I BB stop hey stop trying to
jump out the pot so if you don't accept
that as your source for Jesus speaking
Aramaic what is your Source it's not
relevant it's it's not it's not relevant
ladies and gentlemen it's not relevant
when my man here Lee says that
everything that I know about Jesus comes
from the Quran and as soon as I ask him
one question about Jesus that he doesn't
get from the Quran all of it falls now
all of a sudden it's irrelevant do you
see the hypocrisy okay I'm not saying
that I know 100% for sure what language
he spoke really because Allah because
Allah didn't tell us that in the Quran
then why in the world did you say arama
in Hebrew I said that that was claims
that were made about him that's not what
you said you said he spoke said that
langu wait wait you didn't say that when
I asked you you said he spoke the
language of his people at the time which
was Hebrew and Aramaic those are your
exact words if you want to rewatch this
it's on YouTube you can rewind it you
said that exactly so you didn't say oh
this is what people say he might that
would be my educated guess okay that
would be my educ
right you have an educated you have an
educated guest that Jesus spoke Aramaic
and Hebrew based on what source is this
education coming from the language that
they that the Hebrews wrote at that time
what do you mean how do you know that
Jesus was living in a time where he
would have been speaking AIC and Hebrew
and how do you know that Jesus himself
spoke the language because just because
he lives around people who speak it
doesn't mean that he's speaking it
himself what is your evidence your
source that he spoke at himself just
because somebody makes a CLA that that
doesn't that doesn't validate the Bible
though is what I'm trying it doesn't
validate it hey stay in the if I made a
book and I said if I made a book and I
said God Logic the language of his
people at that time hey stay in the pot
what's your source for your educated
guest bro you doing too much with that
bro just waiting what's your Source bro
I just made an educated guess okay I'm
not say bro I'm not saying I know 100%
sure I do not know so do know I got you
so do you see how let me let let me just
ask you this let me just forget that
then let me ask you this where did Jesus
preach to the people of Benny Israel I
said where not to who where you're
you're trying to ask me all biblical
questions no I'm just asking you basic
questions on Jesus like the language he
spoke I think that that's a basic
question where he preached I think
that's a basic question where did he
preach because your Quran says that he
preached the the gospel your Quran says
that where did he do that I don't know
and it's not relevant I I don't know
100% you know all right what's the
what's your educated guess according if
if if I'm using I I don't I don't know
do you have an educated guess no so you
had an educated guess on the language he
spoke but you don't have an educated
guess on where he preached the people of
Ben Israel they were what do you mean
they was in that area okay sure what
area that's what that's that's a claim
that's that that's something that's
something that was been claimed okay
that's something that's been claimed
what area were they in bro okay
according to your book it says they were
in one area who whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa don't my book is unreliable
remember what area were they in it's not
relevant it's not relevant the question
the question is the what's relevant is
what what is he preaching it's what was
he teaching wherever he's at what was he
teaching all right I'll give you another
one you know what forget it forget what
he spoke forget where he preached who
are his disciples what do you mean they
were Muslims who were they fact you
don't even got to tell me all of them
give me one name bro anyways you said
you know everything about Jesus from the
Quran give me one name of his disciple
bro all of the important all of the
important information of Jesus is
through the Quran okay all of the
important you know what okay you got me
you got me there all of the important
information about Jesus is in the Quran
how did he pray yes how did he pray he
prays like a Muslim that simple show me
he said I
he said I indeed am a Muslim show me how
he prayed however Allah will him to do
Allah I don't know Allah knows best wait
you don't think it's important to know
how your Messi what I do not know do not
know you don't you think it's important
to know how your Messiah prayed and how
he probably taught how to pray you don't
think that's important when he comes
back he will pray like like a Muslim
when he comes back he will pray like a
Muslim but when he was here on Earth how
did he pray I can only assume that he
prayed like Muslim you can only assume
that he prayed like a so no answer to
that huh no answer to that important
question it's not relevant it's not
relevant okay how okay how did Adam wait
wait wait it's not relevant how Jesus
the Messiah prayed and taught how to
pray but just a few seconds ago you said
that you know everything about Jesus and
you know it from the Quran so do you see
how really with basic questions you
don't know nothing about Jesus you don't
know what he preached where he preached
how he preached to who he preached to
specifically you don't know who his
disciples were if he chose his disciples
how he chose them who they were what did
they preach you don't know none of that
yet he trusted them to do it you don't
know none of that you don't know how he
prayed how he taught to pray wait you
know what here's another question did
Jesus fast wait wait about I can ask you
this about literally any prophet in the
Bible did he fast he was a Muslim he did
exact exactly what God wanted him to do
did he fast bro you're asking me for a
biography on his whole life but you said
you know everything about you said you
know everything about Jesus and you know
it from the Quran I didn't say I know
everything about you said you know yeah
you did you said you everything you know
I've never made that claim not once all
right let me not misrepresent you you
said that you know uh you know about
Jesus and the information you know about
Jesus is from the Quran and then when we
tested that you said well the important
things I know about Jesus are from the
Quran but the important things like how
he prayed you don't know that what about
his fasting did he fast that's what you
subjectively believe is more important
than another thing a lot revealed was
what's important to the people oh so now
what's important is subjective so when
we bring up things you can subjectively
decide whether what I bring up is
important or not so that you can use
that as your scapegoat do you see what's
happening here okay now now you just qu
you just put me through a whole
questioning okay tell me what language
did Adam speak this was the very first
person that was created in your Bible to
prove a point to prove a point the Bible
doesn't say the Bible doesn't say you
see I I I did this I did this to prove
to you a point that now notice let me
show you the reverse with me and Adam
everything that I know about Adam comes
from the Bible whatever is not mentioned
about Adam in the Bible I don't know
nothing about you see how I did that I
rely on the Bible you claim to not rely
on the Bible but you think you know
things about Jesus you get what I'm
saying but yet the things that you say
that you know about Jesus comes from the
Bible like him speaking Aramaic for
example or him living in a time and a
place where people spoke Hebrew and
Aramaic that all comes from the Bible
not your Quran not your Hadith so do you
see the difference here I'm being
consistent with my position while you're
not okay and I'm consistent with that
view like I said I don't know I can only
make an educated guess on what you can't
you can't make consensus you can't make
any educated consensus consensus on by
who who's the consensus within taper
within T whenever they're within taper
they'll speak on things and or they'll
give they'll expound on different things
they just they disagreed on on on Jesus
a lot on the language he spoke or
whatever they disagree they had
different opinions but here's the thing
when it they have different opinions
something that where would they have
gotten it from where would they have
gotten it from that he would have spoken
Hebrew or Aramaic some of them Deni that
he spoke Aramaic and only spoke Hebrew
um but where would they get this
information from that he spoke Hebrew or
Aramaic where did they get that from
they would get it from the Jews they
would get it from the Jews where are the
Jews getting it from what do you mean
where would the Jews be getting it from
what language Jesus spoke they had their
own they have their own commentaries and
where did their commentaries get it from
what's their Source I don't know see all
of this just to avoid acknowledging that
the source is the Bible all of that all
all of that just to avoid saying all
right logic all right Avery it's enough
I give up you're right you know even
though I didn't say so you're saying mus
you're saying the Muslim the Bible wait
so you're saying the Muslims that wrote
tap SE or you're saying their Source was
the Bible oh yeah a lot a lot of their
sources come from the Bible their
information about Jesus the Jews the
previous prophets a lot they they take
from the Bible a lot actually okay I
actually you know what I I'll do a fun
session I'll do an entire YouTube uh
might do a live stream I'll make it a
live stream so we can go deep into it
and uh I'll show you the top Seer that
are pulling from the Bible for their
commentary in Islam I'll show you that
it's actually an interesting subject so
look this is how we got here we got here
because we were comparing Muhammad and
Paul and we were seeing the double
standard from our friend here of his
accusations against Paul but if they're
turned on Muhammad then Muhammad's also
an unreliable false prophet you see how
this goes man so if you're gonna say
that Paul is false and unreliable you
have to say the same thing about M okay
I'mma Paul wait okay but Paul claimed to
be a liar Paul claimed to be a liar yes
Paul claimed to be a liar so whoever
lies is a false messenger is that right
he claimed himself that he was a liar so
whoever lies is a false messenger is
that right claimed that that was his
character being a liar is your character
so whoever lies is a false messenger is
that correct go ahead say yes I'm not
saying wait I'm not saying that a person
if Paul is a liar is a can lie any wait
anybody can lie we're all humans right
I'm saying being a liar
uhhuh and that being your character is
not the same thing do call someone
falling what do you call someone who has
lied what do you mean what do you call
someone who tells lies depends on the it
depends on the case and Le this is where
I got there's a thing I'm move on from
here man I'm gonna move on from here I
do appreciate you coming up man it was
fun I'm gonna let the next guest come up
okay okay but there's a such thing as a
white lie and you telling lies like
boldfaced lies that's there a difference
got you I got you well you have a good
day man thanks for coming all right bro
all right woo man what do you do with
that that was fun I'm not going to lie
lean made that fun he was a good sport
about everything he made that fun